welcome back to the show we once again
join scp-682 and its trusty macaw
sidekick Jerry deep in the depths of the
liminal Abyss known as the back rooms
the hard to destroy reptile had been
seemingly contained within the back
rooms for such a lengthy period of time
that it was likely even the SCP
Foundation had given up on searching for
it after unintentionally no clipping out
of reality 682 was apparently doomed to
wander these endless Labyrinthian
realities until the end of its miserable
existence the latest level it had
arrived in appeared to take the form of
a vast desert stretching from Horizon to
Horizon sandstorms buffeted the creature
and Powerful gusts of wind forced Jerry
to take refuge clinging tightly to its
much larger friends back this was level
16 but there was far more to it than
first met the eye as the lizard and bird
made their way across the Titanic Dunes
strange lights began to Circle in the
air about above these were entities
known as light Guides singularities of
pale light that bore a strong
resemblance to Willow the Wisp ghostly
fire Elementals out of folklore much
like the mysterious wisps of Legend
light guides appear to Travelers in the
back rooms Whenever there is an
impending danger you'd think with all
the malicious entities and bizarre
hazards that scp-682 had encountered in
the previous levels it would have seen a
lot more of these but considering how
dangerous 682 itself was the light
guides probably had their non-existent
hands full keeping other Travelers away
from it either way their numbers and
proximity meant that whatever was about
to happen was going to be something
perilous Jerry squawked and nibbled at
scp-682 with his beak trying to warn the
reptile of the danger 682 had no idea
what to expect but made sure to have its
guard up and keep its avian companion
close the creature's instincts were
sharp as ever and the second that the
level began to rearrange itself 682 was
already taking evasive action the sand
hardened and turned to stone as great
pyroclastic flows began to erupt from
what were once the dunes 682 leaped
across a deep fissure just as it opened
up beneath the lizard's feet narrowly
avoiding a several hundred foot drop
into a lake of lava Ash rain from the
sky as all traces of the desert were
completely overwritten into this new
volcanic landscape this was the defining
Supernatural feature of level 16 an
environment that randomly reshaped
itself into different geographical
climates and terrains now that it had
seen the level change completely once
scp-682 was already over the concept
rather than stick around and take a bath
in the lava
scp-682 decided to follow the light
guides towards what appeared to be a
portal made out of concentrated blue
light it passed through the portal and
found itself in a cramped hallway
resembling those of aboard a nautical
vessel out with level 16 and in with
level 17 otherwise known as the naval
aircraft carrier though there was no
actual deck of the proverbial carrier
nor any potential aircrafts in the back
rooms for it to transport there didn't
seem to be much happening on level 17 at
least in comparison to the DraStic
terrain shifting of level 16. there were
also absolutely no entities to be seen
as far as 682 could tell of course level
17 was faxing to the reptile in a
different way the corridor it found
itself in was such an extremely tight
fit moving freely was next to Impossible
the back rooms was once again
telegraphing the fact that it was made
with humans and not overgrown lizards in
mind waste of effort 682 thought to
itself not even the most disgusting
human had enough dumb luck to make it
this far after a few minutes of struggle
682 shrunk down to a more manageable
size so it could Traverse the hallways
it was now roughly the size of a male
hyacinth macaw that is to say
jerry-sized and it crawled through the
narrow corridors of level 17 with room
to spare there was still no sign of
hostile entities and given the
propensity for clumps to come
avalanching out of the woodwork on
previous levels 682 saw this as a mercy
it was also grateful to no longer be
exposed to the elements on level 16.
scp-682 passed the time exploring this
seemingly empty corridors by having
one-sided small talk with Jerry the
Macaw couldn't do much more than chirp
and squawk back and before too long 682
realized that it had very little to talk
about its main interests were
slaughtering living things and breaching
containment and both of these topics
were irreverent to the current mood a
wave of embarrassment washed over the
creature as for the first time it had
genuine concern that a social
interaction could go poorly it didn't
want to frighten Jerry away or come
across as awkward it was just that
conversation with like-minded anomalies
had been far easier at the foundation
since the shared experience of being
contained was always a good starting
point the reptile also had fond memories
of the time it got to chat with
scp-079 an old AI that the foundation
secured around the same time as itself
though it was an unusual feeling for a
creature so filled with contempt and
hatred
scp-682 had started to realize that it
wanted to build the same kind of rapport
with Jerry maybe getting lost in the
back rooms was exactly the kind of life
experience it needed to become more
approachable to the few beings it could
respect that being said the current
level it was on was rather underwhelming
as a way of making memories just then
scp-682 saw what appeared to be an
ordinary human up ahead it had its back
turn to the reptile and Jerry and seemed
to be unaware of their presence a
sitting dark oh good a distraction
thought the flustered lizard I was
totally sounding like I had no life
scp-682 charged toward the human as fast
as its shrunken body could carry it
Jerry followed suit flapping his wings
and flying alongside 682 as the duo
approached the human began to turn
around what 682 anticipated was a look
of abject horror on the human's face but
instead The Entity simply stared through
682 as if the reptile wasn't even there
682 was confused but even stranger was
the fact that its Consciousness was
starting to fade 682 blinked and in what
felt like a second later it awoke at
full size half wedged in an aircraft
carrier doorway Jerry was squawking up a
storm and that was presumably what had
woken 682 back up it also seemed that
making eye contact with that humanoid
entity had somehow caused 682 to faint
temporarily The Entity itself was long
gone much to 682's Chagrin this
phenomenon was easy enough for any
expert in backroom's lore to explain as
level 17 was home to Unique entities
known as imprints which resembled humans
but had the supernatural ability to
induce brain death in anything that
looked them in the eyes even so this was
an unacceptable outcome to scp-682 had
the entities been growing stronger as
the level number went higher or was the
reptile simply losing its mental
fortitude maybe all the strange
properties of this place were
compounding on the creature and slowly
making it go soft 682 shrunk down again
and shook off the shame of its encounter
with the imprint the only way to prove
that it was better than the back rooms
was by advancing through all the levels
and taking down whatever entities stood
in its way this would probably mean
facing at least one more pompous jerk
with a spear like tiny and Argos before
and 682 relished the chance to Triumph
in another bout of single combat besides
if another fair fight like those were to
take place 682 would be able to show off
how strong it was to Jerry that alone
was reason enough to find the entrance
to the next level the time for brooding
was over it was now time for action and
adventure even if it took 100 years 682
would not rest until it made it through
every level of the back rooms and left
the entire hellish Dimension devoid of
the life it so despised it wandered the
hallways of level 17 until it found a
door that was discolored compared to the
other ones almost as if there was a
photo negative Spotlight shining on it
from the other side it was about to pass
through when the same imprint it had
encountered earlier stepped into the
hallway
fool me once 682 growled and confidently
initiated a staring contest with the
creature that feeling of losing
Consciousness was felt immediately but
this time 682 suppressed it through
sheer well with all of its vast brain
power it fought to stay away break and
even began to concentrate the
distressing emotions into its gaze the
imprints stood and continued to look at
682 but within mere moments The Entity
was frothing at the mouth and falling
backwards against the wall as the
effects of its own stair were reflected
back at it through a mirror 682 may have
been caught off guard the first time but
its signature adaptation abilities meant
that there was never a second time exit
stage right the reptile opened the door
to the next level and moved on to level
18 which was known as the level of
memories level 18 was said to take on a
subjective appearance that was different
to every individual Wanderer but would
usually resemble a place from childhood
this was no different for 682 and the
hard to destroy reptile was shocked to
find itself in the very same primeval
Forest where it and its countless
siblings first went to war against
ancient humankind there were even
corpses littered around like in the
future hallways of level 15 only these
dead creatures were far more familiar to
the reptile the vast majority were human
Warriors in Bronze Age armor still
gripping Antiquated weapons such as
swords and axes among these Fallen
humans were the occasional dead giant
beasts though these bodies were rather
few in number as casualties on the
scp-682 side of this war had been almost
non-existent 682 had never thought it
would see this place or those of its
kind that were too weak to survive the
battlefield again it was a strange and
uncomfortable feeling not helped by the
raspy Whispering voices that seemed to
linger in the Wind of level 18. your
father will never look for you for he
has already transcended that momentary
flash of anger that brought you and the
rest of your litter into being he only
has further use for your mother his
bride
she is worth a million of you no matter
how many battles you fought in the name
of his hate despite the ghoulish
intensity of the whispering voices the
words they said were clear and direct
impossible to mistake but the part that
really caused scp-682's blood to boil
was the fact that these voices seem to
know more about its past than even the
foundation did tell me disgraced Prince
of Wrath what hurts more the fact that
you proved weak enough to fall into the
clutches of your greatest enemies or the
fact that those same lab coats and
soldiers were the first ones that
allowed you an identity of your own
distinct from the whims of your pathetic
father lost in the wicked siren song of
level 18's voices 682 suddenly noticed
that Jerry had flown off again or
perhaps he had never entered level 18
with the reptile at all all had called
out for the Macaw but there was no
answer 682 found all of this to be very
distressing especially since these
Whispers seem to come from some powerful
unseen force that knew exactly what the
reptile viewed as its greatest failures
it was different from the influx of
negative thoughts that level 14 caused
since that had been a product of 682's
own mind what was happening here on
level 18 was different a separate
malevolent Consciousness perhaps the
creator of the back rooms itself was
completely aware of all of six City
two's childhood trauma and was
deliberately using it against the
creature physical threats were one thing
that 682 had always been able to
overcome but a psychological attack of
this degree was beyond the capabilities
of even the foundation still there had
to be a way out of level 18 or at least
a way back to Jerry either would have
given 682 a bit of breathing room from
the influence of The Whispers
fortunately things weren't quite as dire
as they seemed as scp-682 was about to
be reminded that not all the entities in
the back rooms meant to do harm enter
entity 198 nicknamed the plush dino by
the explorer who first discovered it
while level 18 is not the only level of
the back rooms it can appear on the
plush Dino often patrols the reality of
childhood memories in search of
Wanderers in distress and in the
compromised psychological state it was
in right now
scp-682 surprisingly fit that
description thus prompting entity 198 to
come to its Aid at first
scp-682 didn't know what to make of this
peculiar synthetic looking entity it
approached with no ill well and
wordlessly attempted to comfort the
reptile through gentle contact
scp-682 swiped at the creature with its
claw as always it was not in the mood
for cuddling with a stuffed toy entity
198 seemed to be able to dodge the
reptiles attacks easily and continue to
do so as 682 made repeated attempts to
destroy it nothing connected and the
plush Dino circled the hard to destroy
reptile without a scratch what do you
want from me you worthless little creep
682 screamed at the dino at which point
The Entity turned and started to speed
away in a random Direction 682 gave
Chase pursuing entity 198 through its
own childhood memories towards what
appeared to be the door that had led it
into level 18 to begin with the blush
Dino opened the door and proceeded to
walk the dinosaur into the door without
even considering whether doing so would
send itself back to level 17
scp-682 followed the plush Dino and
instead found itself in the back rooms
level 19. the attic turns out that being
blinded by anger always helps one get
further in life that's a positive lesson
with no unfortunate implications Jerry
had already arrived in level 19 prior to
682 so chasing the plush Diner was even
more more of a smart decision than the
reptile could have imagined Jerry 682
said running up to the Macaw and wagging
its tail Jerry fluttered down from the
attic Rafters and landed on 682's snout
682 a high he squawked having remembered
682's designation number apparently he
had been paying attention to the
conversations earlier this means that
682 had confirmation that it hadn't
totally screwed up this new friendship
yet on top of that it was nice to know
that Jerry had no intention of
abandoning the reptile this was
certainly a warm and touching reunion
though the continued presence of the
smugly grinning plush Dino almost ruined
it 682 snapped its head towards the
offending entity and barked an insult at
it hoping that it would get the message
and leave but entity 198 did No Such
Thing preferring to silently watch the
wholesome interaction between 682 and
Jerry from a safe distance whatever 682
thought it wasn't going to waste any
more time on the impish little stuffed
animal that's when Jerry swooped down
and landed next to the plush Dino 198
Jerry squawked he then waddled across
the wooden attic floorboards in between
682 and 198 and squawked again it was as
if he was trying to introduce the two
and this mortified 682 was this thing a
friend of Jerry's and if so did that
mean he was going to have to co-exist
with it at the very least the plush Dino
didn't seem to be alive in the
conventional sense but whether that
meant it was an animated object or some
kind of machine remained as vague and
mysterious as most things in the back
rooms even though it didn't technically
fall into the very broad category of
living organism that 682 wanted to wipe
out that didn't automatically disqualify
the miniature monster as being
disgusting especially if the dinosaur
was getting overly friendly with Jerry
the blue Hyacinth Macaw belonged to 682
and it didn't feel like sharing
especially not with some clingy toy
after the awkward introductions were
over 682 and its two tagalong companions
had a look at level 19. it definitely
resembled the attic of a household
complete with Dusty discarded furniture
and several boxes of photo albums and
other mementos there was also the orange
glow and unusual fiery light that
emanated from beneath the floorboards
scp-682 didn't know why but the glow
reminded it of the same memories that it
just had to relive on the previous level
this time though 682 was drawn to
thinking about the more positive aspects
of its proverbial childhood if one could
call crushing human skulls beneath its
claws and facing down entire armies of
humans to be positives the truth was
that scp-682 was being mildly affected
by the orange glow of level 19 which had
the memetic ability to insinuate its way
into the former memories of anyone who
wandered through the level but 682 had
spent enough time having its childhood
doing today and decided to search for
the exit after all if there were no
entities present on this floor it would
be a waste of time to stick around and
play into the hands of whatever was
making that orange glow thankfully it
seemed that the entity 198 was already
one step ahead of 682 in the hunt for an
exit the plush Dino had located a
severely damaged wooden door with the
number 20 painted in orange on its
surface no doubt this was the entrance
to the next level
scp-682 was still very annoyed that the
plush Dino had insisted on hanging
around but if it was going to actually
be useful the reptile would be sure to
make the most of it 682 Jerry and the
dino entered the broken doorway and
found themselves inside of a wide open
Warehouse room there were several
corridors leading out of the room that
appeared to be filled with crates on
wooden and plastic pallets this was
level 20. the warehouse although it
resembled many earlier floors of the
back rooms it was surprisingly finite
both the corridors and the room were not
of an unusual size compared to their
equivalence in the real world and
according to explorers the warehouse
itself was only about 300 kilometers
wide at the most those stats weren't
especially impressive if you asked
scp-682 whatever happened to the
infinite labyrinths of liminal spaces
scp-682 wondered ever since the city
level it's been nothing but confined
spaces weird mind screw ones and that
landscape that kept changing for no
reason what happened to the classic back
rooms
scp-682 quickly came to its senses and
realized what it was thinking classic
back rooms it sounded like one of those
snobby Foundation researchers deciding
what was a genuine SCP and what wasn't
based on some incredibly arbitrary
standard besides there were no levels of
the back rooms that were remotely
acceptable for 682 other than maybe
level 9 and breaking them down into
further categories went against the
reptile's ultimate goal of destroying
this horrendous place and everything
associated with it it wouldn't become
like the foundation it hated by being
specific and thorough broad sweeping
statements were more scp-682 style and
when it came to the back rooms every
level was equally disgusting 682 turned
to its Companions and growled with what
seemed to be excitement Jerry let's get
moving you two piece of garbage dinosaur
now go check out could stp682 be
contained in the back rooms and scp-682
Slaughters through the back rooms for
more of our favorite reptilian Menace
taking on the back rooms